so just a few words of welcome everybody
on this delightfully warm evening first
thing to let you know that the usual bad
wine and bad company after the lecture
is cancelled tonight because the
students have organized instead the
green builders association that will
organized a greenhouse ball over and
learn a halt at nine o'clock to which
everybody's invited in which both the
wine and the company will be
considerably better than usual and they
wanted to make it clear to you that
you're all very very welcome but the
main point of welcome here is just to
welcome what's actually quite a large
team that's been working on this
saarinen project which has been going a
long time now and it's enormously
important and successful and in fact I
have up in my office always in a
photograph of Saarinen and one of his
clients staring into a model and what's
interesting is that the client looks
like an architect and saarinen looks
like a client so there's certain the
thing about saarinen there are so many
ways in which his brilliance demands
analysis but always exceeds analysis and
I think what's great about this latest
rethinking of Sarah and Sarah and a
hundred now is that siren just becomes
more and more interesting like it just
seems that the more you uncover the more
he escapes the analysis and so on but I
think it has been quite a wonderful
project and exhibition and scholarship
and it's particularly nice to walk with
my colleague Dean Stern from Yale who's
played a key role in supporting this
project and it seems to me it is
hopefully a project that will go another
50 years of trying to understand how
this particular sort of uber interesting
architect continues to be a challenge to
say the very least he's an enormous
challenge to young architects today
because they really do work that
ultimately would be placed alongside of
his and not necessarily look that good
and if you look in the sarin and Arsenal
he has 11 12 13 14 projects all of which
generally can be placed
side some of the most experimental work
in recent years and still looks better
now I think there will be a moment when
he will lose but it didn't in my opinion
it didn't happen here it simply we
simply don't have works of the order of
TWA and and airports and and so on we
don't have contemporary work of that
standard and that's before you start to
speak about the architects who were and
whose success is unthinkable outside of
Saarinen's the obvious case being Hudson
and the Opera House competition and so
on so so there's not just let's say the
generosity and power of the work itself
but actually the the extent to which
sarin and was a kind of unofficial
teacher for several generations and I
think in a certain sense what what you
have all done with this project is
returned siren and to the role of a
teacher by virtue of reminding us of the
nature of the practice and the work so
that's very clear in the panel's of
tonight and tomorrow for example the
thinking through the question of media I
think which is tomorrow's panel there's
this opened so many doors into
contemporary practice so anyway just to
say welcome I remember the moment I
don't know if it was a year ago
something like that when I think else
and and and Donald was saying well look
since we're going to do this thing at
the Museum could it be possible that we
would have the conference here at
Columbia and I can only say that the
nicest thing about this evening is the
is the little that I had to do with it
which is which is to say not just in
from the point of view of my congenital
laziness but actually that it's it's for
us a great privilege to act for a moment
as a host to a part of this project and
again I want to thank Bob in the rest of
you for this amazing work and and it's
been very nice to know that Reinhold in
a way sort of has been our ambassador at
the heart of this project and at some
level Columbia was you know in the
chorus but I think I really want to say
we're in the chorus and we want it in a
way welcome a really really spectacular
project and I think it's very nice for
those of us in
room from Columbia to listen in to the
kind of thinking as its evolved and I
think you're in the last weekend of the
show so I also like the discussions that
happen at the end are generally better
than the discussions that happen at the
beginning so I think might be quite
special this particular one anyway
welcome very much and I'm literally
handing the school over to the sermon
and project Thank You Dean Woodley for
the introduction I'm Julia Costa I'm the
director of the Finnish Cultural
Institute one of the three organizers of
the Arizona and shaping the future
exhibition that also the whole entire
show saarinen project encompasses India
in addition to the exhibition also
two-year research project that was led
by Ava Lisa Belconnen one of our
speakers today as well as the
publication of this book as a result of
that two-year research project the book
has done extremely well and has won
several significant awards such as the
sir banister flexure award for the best
book in art and architecture in 2006 as
well as the Philip Johnson best
exhibition catalogue in 2006 so today
we're here to reflect on the
contemporary relevance of the work of
arrows RNN and this is around the time
of his centenary but also this is almost
50 years after his untimely death and
the amazing condensed very successful
career that he managed to go through
with in a time of about ten years in his
40s and we're going to have three
speakers two of whom have contributed to
this book so Emma Lisa belconnen who was
the leader of the research
team as well as Reinhold Martin who
contributed to the book and then the
third speaker is speaking as a
practicing architect mark Tamaki of the
lowest Aramaki Lewis ltl our cadets and
without going into any further detail
about the project or Saarinen's career
which I'm sure Ava and mine hope will
talk plenty about I will just briefly
introduce the speakers and let them do
the rest of the talking so I beleza
belconnen is an associate professor at
Yale School of Architecture where she
teaches design history and theory of
architecture and directs the Masters of
environmental design program she holds a
Master of Architecture from Tom Barrett
Technical University in Finland a
masters of environmental design degree
from Yale as well as a PhD from Columbia
University and she's the author of three
books octave architecture image and
phantasm in contemporary Austrian
architecture and this the arrows are in
and shaping the future which she
co-edited with the exhibition curator
Donald Albrecht and al rato architecture
of modernity and geopolitics which was
published by yale university press in
2009 currently she's working on doing
research on Kevin Roche an architect who
was Sauron and swine right-hand man and
who guided through many of the important
works of Sauron and that were still not
completed at the time of his death I
believe that this is also going to turn
into an exhibition as well as a book and
today we will be talking about Soren and
search for communicative form and
Reinhold Martin is
associate professor here at Columbia he
also directs the ph.d program in
architecture as well as the temple hone
we all center of the study of American
architecture he is a co-founding editor
of the journal gray room and has
published widely on the history and
theory of modern and contemporary
architecture he is the author of the
organizing organizational complex
architecture media and corporate space
the co-author with canonbury boxee of
multinational city architectural
itineraries and his new book on
post-modernism titled utopias ghost is
forthcoming the spring from the
university of minnesota press and he
will be talking about what is material
and Saarinen's relationship to material
and then marks Rumaki is an architect
and a founding partner of Lewis to
remark a Lewis an award-winning design
partnership that explores the
opportunistic overlap between form
program and materiality the new
york-based firm has completed academic
institutional residential and
hospitality projects through the United
States and was awarded the 2007 National
Design Award for interior architecture
as well as the 2007 James Beard Award
for Best restaurant design their work is
part of several museum collections and
has been exhibited wildly and written
about a lot he's also co-author of
opportunistic architecture that was
published in 2008 as well as situation
normal pamphlet architecture number 21
the firm's current work includes our
hosts which is a center for
not-for-profit organization in Austin
texas a villa in orders inner mongolia
as well as a new administrative campus
for the Claremont University Consortium
in California he's currently serving as
on the board of trustees for the Van
Allen Institute on the jury for the 2009
cooper-hewitt national design awards and
the 2009 panel to award grants in
architecture for the New York State
Council for the Arts and now I will give
it over to ever thank you is this a good
like it good distance silence
architecture and its reception has
always hinted the question of form its
genesis and its meaning and that's
something actually that the words
shaping kind of alluded to this idea of
for making that was one of the enigmas I
think for all of us by the way where do
i how do I go forward with the keyboard
that's brilliant
he's somewhat unorthodox approach to
form particularly its relationship to
structure is apparent in these two chair
designs on the left you see a patent
drawing for the famous to lib chair that
for me personally was the kind of
trigger for this exploration as you
might know the story goes that the floor
installed the client in this case as for
a chair that would get rid of the slum
of legs so there was this sort of
conceptual premise and what is
intriguing about this that if you know
the chair and you probably do it looks
like it's uniform material looks very
seamless monolithic but when you look at
the section there's actually a huge the
lake is hollow and it has a huge clump
of Steel hidden you know that works as a
you know keeps keeps the balance so in a
way that the form itself doesn't reveal
how it actually works something similar
is at stake at the chair on the right
which is the GSR and and designed in
1940 with Charles Yves for the organic
home design in home furnishings
competition at MoMA a competition they
were in this case the conceptual premise
was quite wonderful the idea to combine
the seed the arm rests and the back into
one one single form by bending it's
actually the first case where you been
plywood in two direction which was quite
difficult and the original intention was
not to upholster the chair but because
the plywood started splintering they had
to do so so again in both cases one
could say that the conceptual idea and
the formal diagram came first technique
and structure where figured out later so
that's the
radicalness of his for making that I'm
after tonight so three interpretations
of how his forms came into being and
what they meant have dominated his
reception since the first buildings for
the General Motors Technical Center his
breakthrough project were built in
Warren Michigan in the early 50s the
first one put forward by Philip Johnson
in the nineteen fifty two exhibition
built in the USA post-war architecture
argued that the styling building seen
here in the picture followed structural
and material logic and if you look at
the text here it starts simply by saying
constructed in steel framed filled with
blocks of freaks and class something of
that sort so the interpretation applied
that Sonnen was a solid modernist worth
you of momos endorsement the second
interpretation which emerged in the
popular press around the same time is
captured in this fashion photographs
from the look magazine they used the
same building styling building as a
backdrop for these depictions of the new
look by highlighting the building slick
material qualities and luxurious
atmosphere and an article at the plate
Playboy magazine at the same time
Playboy magazine out of all places gave
these this type of quality is an
explicit representation our quality by
arguing that the experience finesse and
high imagination characterizing us
design was superior to the less-is-more
attitude of the Europeans so here there
is no talk about structural logic it's
all about effects atmosphere and so
forth
historians of the modern movement
particularly Europeans were less into
astok about Sun and foremost excu
brunette fit into the modernist canon
Bruno therapy for example commenting in
1956 on the newly finished buildings at
MIT the kreski chapel and auditorium
denounced saarinen as a Mannerist
architect breaking off from the form
follows function rule son has offered
embrace of pittoresque historicism at
Yale's mores and styles colleges led to
the final blow of his reputation as a
solid modernist after seeing the
colleges in 1962 Reyner Banham
considered it suspiciously state set
like and proclaimed Yale is a sick place
son and gets only a passing and mostly
unfavorable mention in subsequent
subsequently in major surveys of modern
architecture including professor
frampton's that you your study study
here by the 1980s Sonnen had become
known as the architect hood it as much
if not more than any other to kill the
socio aesthetic project of modernism by
approaching architecture presumably
based on what Panem called the style for
the strong attitude
so how to make sense of silence design
approach without resorting into this
dichotomy between formal effects and
structural logic which has little
relevance in today's architectural
discourse sadness 1956 article six
pillars of architecture the closest he
ever came to defining a set of
architectural principles give some
guidance it is organized into categories
the first three functional interpret the
honest expression of structure and
awareness of our time corresponding to
what he considered the modernist Dogma
form follows function structure and
zeitgeist Sun and called them timeless
principles of architecture the latter
three expression of the building
concerned for Total Environment and
carrying the concept to the ultimate
conclusion put emphasis on perception
and experience this would of course be
four five and six the goal of the second
group was to take the modern
architecture beyond what he called the
measly ABC represented by the three Sun
and supported this argument by a history
lesson according to him 1920s and 1930s
was dominated by the principal form
follows function the 1940s broad
interest in technological and scientific
development and the 50s a Sun inputs it
quote the leaders of the new generation
refused to stop we I shall say because
it was my generation felt that they must
still be time for a search unquote for
sun and the search and these are
actually pictures of all the buildings
that were incomplete at the time of
Simon's death and the complete
posthumously so nine of all but it gives
you a sense of the formal diversity that
we are dealing with and and how
difficult it's been always to make sense
of that for sun and the search meant
most of all filtering through
unprecedented amount of new technical
and for
possibilities bro climatic challenges
and historical precedents he asserted
resource to least making to describe the
many opportunities and choices facing
architects of his generation I quote
they were new and significant things to
done to be done in structure a whole
science of concrete thin
self-construction was developing
exciting new possibilities they were new
and unexplored materials they were new
things coming out of Europe from Corbeau
and his followers and above all the
challenges of the great variety of
problems to be solved see if to indicate
a creative variety of answers than
modern style tolerated he endorsed
borrowing from modern masters in equally
fluid and excessive way and used the
culinary metaphor to describe the
circulation and reappropriation of forms
that characterized mid-century
architecture he writes mixed together
Frank Lloyd Wright Le Corbusier and miss
van de roi make a broth which is more
than architecture in different parts of
the world the ingredients of the broth
have different proportions unquote
increased information led to increased
number of formal choices subsequently
forms could be experienced and
understood in many ways to use darkness
all metaphor meanings to became as
liquid as brought all in all all sun and
suggested that by the late 50s
architects had become information
processors solid used and this is my
main argument today form to govern the
information flow both during and after
its conception in order to achieve this
he called for formal and conceptual
consistency and the need to create a
total environment in order to for the
building to make quote fullest impact
and expression on hood he cites the TWA
term
a successful demonstration of this
approach and I quote I have come to the
conviction that once one embarks on a
concept for a building this concept has
to be exaggerated and always stated and
repeat it in every part of its interior
so that wherever you are inside or
outside the building things with the
same message this is why for instance
the interior of the TWA had to be the
way it is an old in TWA this approach
translated into curvilinear shapes which
which twist and turn endlessly at times
he even compromised structual and
material logic to achieve this formal
consistency and this section is actually
telling this of the curbside where you
see that the structure is actually it
kind of reminds of the tulip chair again
is behind and this is not concrete it's
plaster so it's you know again these
sort of things that really work against
the kind of form follows structure dogma
Charles MC is photograph of a child
climbing on a work surface demonstrates
how the ideal user acted out the
building's form of dynamism the close-up
view of the parents in front make the
point that such totalizing architecture
could never be contemplated from
distance people merged with the
buildings a sign of complete homology
between form and experience sarnus use
of surface patterns for example facade
arrangements that don't rely on
intrinsic material structural or
functional qualities is based on the
same strategy although the formal
outcome differs here formal rigor is
exaggerated to the point that form
starts to govern information flow
the period has concrete facade in his
Oslo embassy which is here in the
picture serves as an example it is
conceived as a Malian wall originally
developed by the engineer Felix a merely
where the load of the floor slabs is
carried by prefabricated panels around
the perimeter of the building without
revealing quite how it works on the
exterior so here you see the way it's
made to the floor it's here then come
the window a floor slab again and then
kind of in an alternating pattern the
next level of elements are stacked up
son and describes how this how
functional structural material factors
and qualities translated into the
surface pattern as follows unquote here
again use either the section so this is
the edge of the of the precast element
and then there are these filler panels
there so he writes the precast facade is
the most interesting and successful part
of this building our attempt was to
integrate the model on which the offices
were all based with the structural
system so that one could conceive all in
all a precast modular system with an
integrated facade material son and
continue to describe how quote as one
walks along the runway in the road next
to it this structural unit seemed to
become changing checkerboard of math and
shiny light and dark surfaces unquote
the pattern is created here by the
passerby who seduced by the flickering
surface starts to look for such
regularity the facade act thus as a kind
of interactive
service interface which activates the
viewer to reenact it's making the
chairperson national expansion memorial
also known as the st. Louis Arch serve
as another example of silence ability to
govern multiple levels of meaning with a
single formal gesture it's seamless
stainless steel surface gives no
indication what is actually how it's
actually constructed in parts and that
the load-bearing concrete structure is
actually hidden behind the stainless
steel cladding and this is one of these
wonderful beautiful working drawings we
were found at the Yale archives which
shows I mean this is remember before
compute the dimensions of every single
piece all of them different of course I
mean it's a mirror also you get two of
the same kind and how they were stacked
up from the two directions and went
quite a incredible tour de force nor
could one tell from a distance that the
structure is hollow and full of
infrastructure including two elevators
which carry people to the top is one of
these are the original renderings with
the women in high-heeled shoes and
period costumes and this is actually how
it was how it was built actually heard
the story that was very extremely
difficult for them to find and elevate
the constructor to build the elevator
and they finally found the artist didn't
want to take the job they found a
company that did ferris wheels to
construct it the form itself mediates
between which is a weighted catenary
curve the form itself mediates between
structural logic geometric principles
and historical
point his son and with the different
arches and here is he actually altered
original design was a which was closer
to catenary curve and and for visual
reasons purely made it made catenary the
arch offers also a case study what can
happen when architecture relies on
purely formal strategies for
communications meanings become unstable
in fact the original meaning of the arch
has now been lost this is the kind of
first first first reception of the of
the arch when it was when Sun was
announced the winner the park
commissioner accused tunnel for
plagiarism plagiarizing be Argentina's
monument for the 20th anniversary of
Italian fascism was quite different
actually much much wider wider arch and
so here to sum up the argument and my my
my own own drawing I couldn't do it with
a computer this idea that the form
governs the information flow that I've
repeated in the course of this lecture
that you know during the design process
Sun and always emphasizes this is the
list of things that you have to consider
the structu the circulation all these
things that somehow then emerged into
104 and after that it can also be
experienced in many ways and gained a
semantic meaning it can be special
meaning it has all sorts of things that
also change in time so it kind of
becomes the sort of funnel funnel
diagram so sarnus reception proves that
what we already know form is the most
difficult and misunderstood concept in
architectural discourse at worst it is
used exclusively to refer to buildings
that depart from regular
geometric shapes his narrow use of the
term was exploited explicit already
during sadness lifetime while the
popular press celebrated his use of such
forms as a welcome departure from the
dominant lead geometric language of
modern architecture he has spread from
Harpers Bazaar which was actually titled
counter revolution in architecture while
historians like Vincent Scully condemned
these same buildings particularly the
Yale hockey rink for quote formal
exhibitionism and structural pretension
we must however however be reminded that
during the 1950's the idea of purely
formal and visual communication had a
larger echo chamber appropriately that
cover of the 1959 met exhibition form
givers at mid-century which included a
big section on saarinen was designed by
cure cook cabbage and this is of course
variant interesting that first of all
that this cover is white I don't know if
you can quite see but there's this sort
of indent the circles and and squares
but the sort of total getting rid of
images of color anything that might have
representation equality and resorting to
a kind of purely formal playvid form and
and and teasing out the expressive
qualities of those those forms his book
caper she's booked language of vision
put forward put forward a thesis how
Forbes communicate on a purely visual
level what cabbage called optical
communication is based on the idea that
quote visual language is capable of
disseminating knowledge more effectively
than almost any other vehicle of
communication it is universal and
international it knows no limits of
tongue vocabulary or grammar and it can
be perceived by the literate as well as
illiterate true sarna's architecture is
not difficult to grasp
is it offers something for everybody I
always say that your grandmother would
get sudden and there's always somebody
you always have an access point I'm the
gay hockey rink is my personal favorite
in this record while a layman might read
the exterior form as a whale or a viking
helmet it is known in New Haven as the
Yale whale the interior has pure
visceral impact anyone who visits the
building particularly during a hockey
game feels invigorated the contemporary
architect is particularly drawn to how
different architectural and programmatic
elements for one another and this is a
interesting first of all it's
interesting to see how the section the
curve used in the section is the same as
the curve the retaining walls at the
exterior and this actually it's better
than any photograph shows how it works
it's quite brilliant the ramp so they
are not going to stairs the ramps take
you to the bleachers it's kind of like
an interior landscape that goes like
this and it merges the you know the
programmatic the structure everything is
merged in the one the form again becomes
the governor of the of the plan the
building proves silence thisis a single
formal move when consistently applied is
the most efficient tool to coordinate
programmatic structural and somatic
information Susan Wagner is 1953
best-selling book feeling and for laid a
philosophical foundation for how forms
into human consciousness and what effect
they have on us while acknowledging that
forms had a special power on the low /
she insisted that the word message was
misleading and replaced it with the
concept symbol which she inherited from
her teacher in scarcer who used it to
refer to wholly sensory experience which
according to him touched the very
essence of human life namely freedom
following Cathedral longer contain
you to believe in the total homology
between aesthetics and ethics between
form and life and here I read a quote
that's very really beautiful that I
don't think I can do it quite justice
symbolic expression is something miles
removed from efficient planning or good
arrangement it does not suggest things
to do but embodies the feeling the
rhythm the passion was a prayer sobriety
frivolity and fear with which anything's
at all are done that is the image of
life which is created in buildings it is
the visible semblance of an ethnic
domain a symbol of humanity to be found
in the strength and interplay of forms
like longer Sonnen seems to have
believed that human beings are
hard-wired to receive aesthetic impulses
that forms touch the inner core of our
humanity like no other medium I would
argue that Sun is best buildings and
here again i would like to refer to the
Yale hockey rink reach this level of
symbolic communication without having to
rely on semantics meanings sunlen seems
to have believed that the ability to
govern information and experience
through such nonverbal and indeed non
cerebral ways became increasingly
important as human beings had to
navigate through more and more
information on daily basis true son and
search for communicative form failed to
address many social problems and he can
be criticized for lacking a player
project but he does not deserve credit
for creating a few spaces and forms
which make one feel at least momentarily
happy to be alive and share a space with
fellow human beings the rest he probably
thought would follow thank you
so I'm told I have 20 minutes in the
spirit of Scandinavian precision and
with respect to give us commitment there
to through the duration of this now more
than five year long project I start the
timer now thanks to everyone for coming
and to our colleagues for for joining us
in what really has been we were
calculating over five years of work and
discussion on Saarinen's work and a very
systematic research project in fact that
I think you know it really is a kind of
unusual exercise in in the context of
traveling exhibitions and such that that
a research team would be brought
together across the Atlantic and and
work together to develop not just an
exhibition and a catalog but a really an
interpretive framework a kind of
strategy way of thinking so so in fact I
hope that a leaf aspects of the
conversation that will have afterwards
would reflect you know
the sort of knowledge and insights
accumulated over those those years so
you know in at the other end of this arc
to refer to arches I sort of thought you
know I realized that that it had been
about about five years it was actually
five years since I at least submitted
the final draft of the article that I
wrote for the book that ever showed you
and so it sort of was the opportunity to
think to reflect really on the content
and
and really arguments in
in that piece and and and try to talk a
little bit about it but more about what
it doesn't say what I have since learned
and or at least since felt it important
to to add two to some of this this
research so in that sense I first I want
to I want to say that it I think one of
the things that we've kind of concluded
in a sense is that saarinen is remains
an enigma I mean as an architect it's
it's always hard to tell whether you can
you're looking at serious architecture
when you're looking at a saurian
building it's also hard to tell whether
to take the writing seriously or the
correspondence and all the other
materials that we have sifted through in
our own ways and you know what level in
what register should this this work and
its surrounding practices be be
interpreted I I would prefer to let it
be let's Ernie remain an enigma it's
more interesting that way and and in
translating into a more contemporary as
it were framework to to suggest that
that we learned to think historically
about such and such enigmas as are
presented by this work and what I mean
by that historically I don't mean that
like like you know citing it or copying
it or
or somehow using it its itself as a kind
of resource for contemporary design I
actually mean to think again about what
it means to historic I work and a body
of a body of work and it's architect and
and so what I want to suggest first is
that in the case of saarinen it might
involve at least it has in my own
interest and work around his work a kind
of consideration of architecture
reconsideration marketed reframing of
architecture very specifically as what
we can call a technical medium and i'll
try to explain what i what i mean by
that in the essay for the catalog I it
was sort of interesting to think about
the materiality of that medium and it's
literally sort of technical production
and I'll show you a couple of slides
from that and the butt and then you know
maybe what can be a door I think I could
add right now to that is is are some
reflections of what we can call a kind
of
immaterial materiality or really more
precisely a material immateriality
because and it's exactly in that sense
that I want to insist that we're dealing
with technical media here so anyway what
the question what is a material is is
the one that I thought it was
interesting to pose to to this work in
the context of the exhibition and the
short answer is that the material a
material any material the kind of
materials that architects use every day
is in a sense in its essence in
essential which means that it is in fact
a cultural construction or to put it
another way a nature culture hybrid so
so here you see this is sorry and
company some of his teams and team and
clients surveying the site for the John
Deere headquarters and and and it's very
important this is a building sort of
famously position to sensitively on its
site and it's important to recognize
that that from the very beginning the
site selection and an orientation kind
of technical apparatus such as the one
that you see here is is necessary and
part in a sense of the production of
the sort of sight at the other end of
that site in a sense where that
production is the material that kind of
what we will traditionally call a
material and architecture because I'm
implying that the site itself belongs to
the material complex of architecture is
this this object is one of one of the
many mock-ups that bizarre infirmed did
for the project for John Deere I'm not
showing you pictures of the project so
much because you should go see the show
if you haven't seen it but but here this
is a mock-up they did on the side of the
court and steal the business Assad to
test how it rusts in the you know in the
weather another sort of similar
procedure this is saarinen Kevin Roche
looking at the stone that was eventually
used in the CBS building which was
mocked up in another mock up and then
again the the sort of invention of a
certain technique for concrete at TWA in
not so much to produce a particular form
but in the interests of as it were
materializing
a sort of abstractions that we call
materiality this is maybe a little
itself abstract that what I mean by that
is the set of forces and the set of
bells at the level of production like
all the engineers and all the apparatus
that's necessary to produce that roof
but also the ideas the techniques the
types of drawings the discourses the
histories all the agents all the kind of
operators and in short what we call a
network of discourses that out of which
an image like that kind of emerges okay
so here's another dumb for you or really
a series of domes this is the kresge
auditorium at MIT kind of photographed
in the way the photographer probably
thought that the architect wanted it to
be photographed as one among many domes
and off to the side you see the chapel
what I would like to just mention at
this point is that is that this
particular project I think represents it
represents a kind of crisis for the firm
and its kind of internal history there
there are problems around the
construction of this dome
you know and so on but but probably but
more and more more to the point here it
represents a kind of problem for us
historically in thinking our categories
in innocence using utilizing an
innocence producing the discursive
categories by which we need to
understand this and what I mean is is
that what this photograph this ensemble
effectively demands is something that I
actually don't think really exists in
any systematic way yet and that is a
properly secular history of architecture
so because what you're looking at of
course is not just an auditorium you're
also looking at a chapel and you're
looking at the implicit correlation of
the dome type the sort of history of
domes that you know including distance
of course eluding the dome over there
alerts to the dome over here at the
library the the relationship between
domes and universities and or to put it
another way religious forms forms with
religious origins
monuments to secular humanism so MIT has
a kind of problem here the problem is
that there's no religion in MIT and this
is this is a significant problem in the
in the post-war period and it's in a
sense the problem that produces the
siren and complex but but what a pretty
no I'm getting ahead of myself a bit
here but what it produces for us is is
is the kind of as a kind of confusion
between secular and religious meanings
when I try to understand these these
works so okay just a little bit of
information the auditorium and chapel
complex were funded by the kresge
foundation who had supported a lot of
religious institutions and they had a
kind of interest in religious education
and they were open in 1955 they would
there were the result of a grant process
that was started prior to the war and it
was it's its Shepherd its kind of
custodian was a figure by the name of
John birchard who was a architectural
historian architect architectural
historian and eventually Dean of
humanities at MIT and the kresge name
was initially to be attached to a
Department of humanities at at MIT that
was meant to sort of counterbalance what
at that by that point even before the
war and especially after the war was was
perceived as the kind of predominance of
kind of instrumental technological or
kind of technocratic
sort of knowledge so so in other words
MIT this is what i mean by the sort of
problem that MIT didn't have religion
was constructed as the problem that i
might even have a soul it was lacking
spirit is pure science pure rationality
pure calculation and so the humanists
were called in a virtue they called
themselves in in the form of figures
like burchard and and it was exactly out
of that process of eventually actually
founding a department of humanities at
MIT that that this strange complex
emerged simply because it it reproduced
the problem it reproduced the problem by
failing to reconcile the humanities and
religion or secular knowledge with
theology in other words the two
buildings you know represented by the
two buildings the dome to the the
auditorium as a kind of kind of secular
bourgeois public sphere in which events
like this would occur and critical
discourse in other words and and the
chapel as as a site of
for the return in effect of theology to
the to the University which you may know
it begins the American most American
universities MIT accepted begin as
religious institutions so so the how do
in a sense to understand is how to
interpret this strange conflict in fact
the two buildings were in the programs
that were written at the beginning they
were meant to be together and this site
plan was only the result of this whole
kind of process institutional process
committees memos jockeying and so on
that that that split them apart so so
what you're looking at in effect is a
kind of contradiction now what is the
architecture of that contradiction let's
say well the each building well I think
it's maybe better put that that each
building in in the ensemble there was
supposed to be a sir there's meant to be
a student union but that was built later
but by dipping another architect but
this is ensemble each one of them
resolves the contradiction in in a
different way and I want to suggest in
its capacity as technical medium and it
does that by manipulating two materials
in together that that we don't always
think of something and sometimes we do
but but in a sense these buildings are
formed around these materials
and those are the materials of light and
sound and and so you know this is partly
what I mean by a kind of immaterial
materiality that it's exactly the
manipulation of light and the
manipulation of sound these material
processes that that much of the
technical expertise the the formal
invention and the discursive let's say
construction of these these two
buildings kind of in folks so okay so
here's the secular bourgeois public
sphere literally it's 18 of a sphere and
and this is a study model when again
many study models the office was quite
famous for that into to set up set up to
study the the workings of the Interior
you see the acoustic panels and then
inside another model the sort of focus
on on this stage both of them involve
the problem of focus which is a formal
problem if you're using this kind of
geometry and and you'll see that that
also has to do the light here's the
photo the light is focused on the stage
as is this and the sound obviously is is
reflected back out
and so you know in that sense this is
this this interior is a kind of machine
for focusing for for paying attention
what's happen like as is this interior
but this is in a sense I'm much more
sophisticated and subtle one a machine
for for focusing attention on on the
events going on on the stage which are
intended as I said to be theater
performances like lectures like this and
other kind of humanistic endeavors this
machine is a different one this is the
interior of the chapel again it's a
machine for focusing attention on the
center and again light is used very very
specifically to to draw that attention
to the center in this case a you know
with this is this is a bit of a the
through the through the kind of
combination of two different sort of
sources to focus the ceiling aperture
shimmering down onto the altar and then
the uplighting
reflecting up off of the water that's
that is in the moat that's surrounding
the building and here's the working drum
was going to leave this here for you to
try to figure out but a great deal of
technique was was involved in developing
these blind arches under which the water
the reflection from the water become
visible on the interior and again the
skylight and
kind of devices sort of at the perimeter
clean guns relating wall and the
interior which you don't really see in
this in this drawing so so this is a
machine for facilitating the return of
theology to to the campus and in and I
think really does need to be understood
in in those terms the two buildings
together materialized quite directly a
kind of contradiction that conflict and
at least an ambiguity that arises from
the encounter between secular humanism
and religion it's a very classic
encounter as i said on American campuses
and architecture is long participated in
this our problem in a sense I think I
want to insist is in effect to
secularize the interpretation of that
encounter which is to say to read to
learn to read it critically and in that
respect in that sense to to take some
distance from from the desire to reclaim
this architecture however deftly it may
be into the
into the sort of Canon a religious term
by the way you probably know of of
modern architecture because to do that
would inevitably and systematically need
to import its kind of crypto theology
and it would it would do so at the
expense I think of a very valuable and
very important idea that what modernism
means is is a kind of form of secular
cultural production and it's one of the
great myths of modern architecture that
it's you know you know very well that
there are many churches and temples and
other such buildings designed by
modernist architects saurian and did
quite a few himself and he usually
manipulated usually use these take these
devices for manipulating the light to to
do them but but it does seem rather
important to kind of move an
interpretive move to do now like in our
in this moment to in a sense resist the
temptation to resolve the contradiction
in in in the form of what we can call
the kind of theological humanism a
humanism that in a sense displace is the
explicit or abstracts to use the
modernist language the the explicit
iconographic and sort of referential
discourse of
particularly Christianity on to you know
this kind of spiritual plane with which
a lot of post who architecture luca pues
es r NN con and others what has been
interpreted we can order to put it the
other way around every time you hear the
word spirit connected with this
architecture you should recognize that
what you're what you're what you're
witnessing is a kind of religious turn
and and that needs to be taken seriously
i think in in effect defense of the very
important enlightenment idea that there
was a difference between secular
knowledge and theology rather than their
their kind of resolution in this
theological humanism so it's a funny
thing because because siren and himself
never really talked about any of this i
mean it was not really a preoccupation
he did worry a little bit that that one
of the problems for architects was
designed chapels he complained that
nobody really knew how to do it when he
was talking about nice and he said this
is maybe something he could contribute
because there were a lot and i think he
had the idea that there was a lot of
this work to be had his father was also
eliel saarinen was an architect of
religious buildings and and so so it's
not you know out of the blue or nothing
but but it's it's it's nevertheless of
its moment it's a very particular moment
in which war had produced a kind of
crisis of a kind of moral crisis
particularly places like MIT where the
bomb was partly produced released the
knowledge that produced it
and it was a desire a kind of a kind of
let's say ethical sort of reflex to try
to correct for that by appealing to this
kind of spirituality in the guise of the
humanities and and
eventually connecting that back up with
with religion so so that so in you know
a way a kind of historical question that
we could ask that's of relevance to to
us now might be something like how could
it have been done differently
with that I think I will leave you
because I this is about to go home thank
you
good evening so I hate to begin this way
but a couple of caveats one is that I
did want to clarify that I'm probably
the one speaker tonight that hasn't been
involved in this sort of longer research
project surrounding sarin in but I've
been asked both as a professor design
professor here at g's and also as a
practicing architect to comment both on
Ryan Holden Ava Lisa's work in the
context of the book but also to a
comment a bit more broadly on the
potential kind of relevance of sarin and
from that standpoint from the standpoint
of an architect in contemporary practice
today this position of course both
worries me a bit but at the same time
what I'm hoping is it gives me a bit of
an excuse for any lack of intellectual
rigor or historical accuracy and the
observations that will follow and I
would like to apologize as well to to
Ryan Holden Ava who have provided me
with a bit of a moving target tonight
since I'll be principally reacting to
their their research as presented in the
book however I did want to make a few
comments tonight as well that begin to
not recuperates Aaron in or to try to
drag him into contemporary discourse as
a kind of progenitor for our obsessions
today but rather to use him in a sense
to unpack certain ideas certain
predictions or or obsessions within his
work which are in many ways still
relevant for us and in some level
assumed or even kind of normalized
within contemporary practice and in that
sense becomes very difficult to examine
so that by looking at the kind of
history
context of sarin and we may be able to
shed some light on these in a somewhat
different way so to begin another risk
of oversimplifying the distinctions
between the presentations we've just
heard here beginning with with reinholds
work they do share this kind of common
theme of identifying contradictions in
serons work between the technical
aspects of materiality and structure on
the one hand and their status as image
and representation on the other in the
case of reinholds essays materials are
seen as comprising not only their
intrinsic natural qualities but also as
complicit in the construction of images
that carry cultural and social meaning a
condition in which material and image
are not conceived as oppositional but
rather is reciprocal and inextricably
bound together the final status of the
building in these instances is therefore
neither a postmodern detachment of
semiotic effect from constructional
reality this is a CBS building mock-up
testing for those panels nor the
modernist honesty in the expression of
material and structure what we're left
with instead is a kind of contradiction
or a paradox in which the conventional
dichotomy between the strictly rational
and the express it were aesthetic
qualities of the building are left in an
unresolved suspension an oscillation
between the corporeal and the immaterial
at which we seem to have expanded
tonight to into the realm of the virtual
and the manipulation of light as an
aspect of material as well similar Ava
Lisa in her a work tracks the emergence
of a preference for the communicative
and expressive dimensions of form and
Sarah needs work again this is seen as
opposed to the first generation
modernist reliance on the purely
functional principles of modernist
discourse or
at the same time a postmodernist
recourse to explicit historical
references the essay suggests that
Sarah's development of immersive
aesthetics predicated on generating a
central perception of space what the
critic Robin Boyd termed felt space is
tied to corresponding contemporary
interests in the communicative potential
of visual arms this was not seen in
terms of a kind of direct symbolic
content of the architectural image as in
TD TWA equals bird in flight but rather
in the emergence of meaning as an
emotional response to psycho spatial
stimuli what is interesting here is is
that the communicate content of Serena's
work is not simply reducible to its
circulation value in an economy of
mediated images publications photographs
or representations but rather directly
tied to a subjective experience of the
building itself nevertheless you suggest
that this trajectory paves the way for a
condition in which the architectural
form becomes increasingly dissociated
from its context or its production in
any case here syren and can be seen and
he was sort of has been famously spoken
of as an architect who recognized the
critical role of contemporary media but
here is well one who understood that the
building itself exists as a form of
media one whose primary function is to
communicate to the viewer through an
assembly of effects in both of these
instances we find sarren an identified
as an architect who would make the
conscious and quote dangerous decision
to privilege the more beautiful over the
quote structural in rational
unquote what is critical here is the
identification of a kind of a moment of
productive paradox when the orthodoxies
of modernist rationality began to give
way to the emergence of new
sensibilities regarding architectures
expanded role in increasingly affluent
consumerist society for sarin and this
meant a broadening of architectures per
view from the narrow qualifications of
dogmatic modernism toward a richer and
more inclusive approach which would
admit a greater variety of answers that
modernist style tolerated this last of
Court of Sarah needs this hybridity of
sarin in practice resulted in divergent
strains of experimentation and
multiplicity of form that generates some
of his harshest criticism as well as
some of his most sort of provocative
work while various elements of
Saarinen's hybridity can be seen as
having reemerged in the form of certain
tendencies within contemporary practice
from the plastic expression of complex
geometries perhaps we figured in the
line of evolution that stretches from
Kresge to ingles hockey rink and finally
to dulles airport or the
experimentations with the material
effects of surfaces often as in
Saarinen's work projects like bell or
IBM articulating otherwise mute
functional boxes what is fascinating
here is to me at least is not the
ability to track the lineages of this
work into the present but rather the
incredible diversity and multiplicity of
approaches that sarin and his
collaborators were actually able to
deploy in a comparatively brief the
wildly prolific
career what can be seen as having
bifurcated into ideologically opposed
directions in contemporary practice say
plastic form versus elaboration of
surface we're in fact being deployed
simultaneously at sarin ins office
presumably without any trepidations
regarding stylistic consistency it is
precisely this inability to be
categorized an inability to locate a
substance or even a consistent style
among the multiplication of forms which
is at once frustrating and fascinating
about serannon just as it is this
perceived multiplicity that led Reyner
Banham to call him with equal parts
admiration and derision the perfect ad
man however the apparent ease with which
sirna negotiated the plurality of formal
strategies in the surface of corporate
clients hell belies the seriousness
which is not to say the obsessiveness
with which he experimented to arrive at
these diverse architectural solutions
and his own critical self awareness
regarding the success and failure of his
work his evaluation for example of the
Kresge chapel or the kresge auditorium
which he'd just seen as looking like a
half inflated balloon or his defense of
the diverse approaches that
characterizes practice what's aaron n
described in terms of a search can be
seen in light of a general sense of
unease and anxiety regarding
architectural practice in discourse that
was sort of in the air at the time in
this sense to for ease later evaluation
of Saarinen's work in terms of pathology
a quote-unquote neurosis of form is not
inconsistent with the evaluations of
sarin and among his professional
contemporaries as ava also points out in
her essay Saarinen's productive period
coincided with not area not only the
area for the era of post-war American
but also a state of unprecedented
pluralism and even confusion within
contemporary architectural practice so
much so that it was dubbed the period of
cayaba scism in a contemporary article
in progressive architecture magazine
what can be seen in retrospect as an
exuberant period were in the
prescriptive aspects of modernist dog
while we're giving way to a vital
experimentation with form structure
materials and technology can also be
seen as a time of increasing anxiety
regarding a crisis of meaning and
architecture it would be perhaps
tempting to note that the anxieties and
potentials that characterize these
debates the loss of any consensual basis
for an architectural aesthetics a
fascination with new materials and
technologies and the potential to
generate form and an apparently
uncritical embrace of new economies as
spaces in which architects to operate
have the parallels in our own situation
whoever is architects practicing in a
context which has become ever more
fragmented complex and diverse it may
seem nostalgic or even quaint today to
look back at CNN's perceived failings
and transgressions and the controversy
that surrounded the Zen radical
proliferation of forms especially in a
time when the pursuit of the newer novel
has reached a kind of fever pitch
well I would want to resist the desire
to drag sarin and into the present as
some form of progenitor for contemporary
practice it nevertheless may be useful
to unpack some of sarin and zone
preoccupations if for no other reason
than to examine issues which are now
assumed and to some degree therefore
taken for granted within architectural
practice today today in this light I
want to conclude by briefly reflecting
on serenades relationship to technology
and experimentation on the one hand and
to methodology and the constraints of
program on the other a great pet sort of
opponent of Orthodoxy sarin and was also
deeply committed to the notion of the
zeitgeist and believe that he was
searching for the appropriate expression
for 20th century culture on the one hand
this surfaced in the obsession with
technical advancement what Vincent
Scully called the web of functional
innovation the neoprene gaskets GM the
core tenets dear the mirror curtain wall
at Bell for example if this mania for
emerging emerging technologies bordered
on the fetishistic prompting one critic
to label the st. Louis Arch an enormous
gadget it also involved an extensive
process of testing and iteration through
the generation of large scale models and
mock-ups of material assemblies this
notion of testing the willingness to
experiment with new techniques in
construction methodologies as well as
notions of technological transference
for example from the automotive industry
to architecture has been has become part
of the ingrained DNA of progressive
architectural practices today at least a
certain strain of them the integration
of advanced forms of fabrication
production and manufacture especially as
regards digital technologies and new
environmental building techniques as
well as the notion of an integrated team
of technical specialists as part of the
design process as gained currency to the
point where these are now
often seen as a sufficient condition for
architectural production it is important
to note here that for sarin and however
the particular technique was always seen
as subservient to the demands and
content of the project at hand for sarin
and these technologies had no intrinsic
or correct expression had to be guided
by the intuition of the designer to find
the appropriate form a process that
required continual testing through
multiple iterations and careful study of
the effects thereof and again photos of
some of these very large scale models
that were employed famously in the
office in the absence also have any
external universally valid formula
Serenade had recourse to several
self-generated principles that he
articulated as three new pillars it was
already referred to these in addition to
the foundational principles of modern
architecture these again were expression
the total environment carrying the
concept through to its final conclusion
I want to just think a little bit about
this kind of last one which is I think a
particular interest to us and that it
would seem to supplant a kind of over
overarching ideological bias or the idea
of an a priori starting point for
architecture with the idea of an
internal consistency to a singular
concept instead derived from the
specifics of the project at hand rather
than an externally generated formal
strategy to be repeated regardless of
program client or context sarin and
employed the idea of a logical
trajectory in which each step was a
result of a rational process it is
perhaps this obsessive consistency and
the willingness to carry through a line
of experimentation or thought to its
ultimate and even extreme conclusion
that perhaps produces the internal
resonance of buildings like the TWA
terminal where the form of seating a
built-in seating or the information desk
can be seen as a kind of reiteration of
the logics of a building of the building
at multiple scales this expressive unity
within the building was in contradiction
to the perception of sarin and as a kind
of cereal stylist
with its implications of the arbitrary
and the capricious it can also be seen
ironically as the very source for the
perceived lack of unity in his work when
is conceived as a totality in defense of
this perceived lack of overall
consistency what was called his
arbitrary eclecticism he countered that
the specifics of each project generated
the logics of the design in each case
each architectural problem he argued
including quote new problems created by
our technology unquote had a unique
solution which derived from the totality
of its concerns and their distillation
into an architectural concept and
serenades word quote the real
significance of the problem this meant
that GM could evidence a technocratic
precision based on the repetition of
modular form albeit hybridized with
touches of sensualism the MIT chapel
could exist as an exercise in the
effects of masonry light and water and
TWA Co traffic in the muscular
exaggeration of structure for perceptual
effect will all would be
methodologically unified by an approach
which has been characterized again by
benim as the right style for the job
Kevin Roche one of his closest
collaborators in the office remarked in
the recent Yale symposium
let's Aaron end quote never began with
form he had an approach rather similar
to a scientist or researcher of starting
with trying to define what is the
problem in which he was quote absolutely
relentless he goes on to say that quote
the process was very slow very very
methodical and very careful and by the
time he got to thinking about forum he
already knew more about the functional
aspects and he had thoroughly
investigated also all of the other
relationships the urban design the
cultural environment all these things
that one normally takes into account
there wasn't a black or white right or
wrong so Evan at any point in time what
there was was this extraordinarily
careful assembly of the information in
research and facts and at the end of the
process the forum would emerge this
insistence on what might broadly be
termed program the collective parameters
constraints and aspirations that define
the project and a method otha methodical
and precise research into their
architectural implications reverses the
common perception of sarin and as a
facile form giver what has been
dismissed as a kind of crass opportunism
on sarin as part as advertising or
branding or a pathological neurosis of
form can here be seen as a kind of
optimistic engagement with the crucial
parameters of each project one that
within almost hedonistic enthusiasm
latched onto the possibilities of new
techniques and materials as well as
emerging formats and programs and so at
the end Cernan presents another kind of
paradox one in which his formal
experimentation which is probably the
condition for which he is best known can
be seen as an effect of a kind of a
shift in methodology one that replaced a
preconceived ideological basis for
architecture with a process-driven
response to a new density of information
thank you
diesel yeah
so thank you so much for extremely
interesting our presentations and I
think it would be good to open it up to
general questions right away if the oil
has some particular questions to address
to anyone of these exons speakers
ok and the last just a second you're
going to get the mic as I guess it's
question for air for Lisa and Julia I
guess to talk tonight certainly it's
talked about ban serene and as an
American architect but yet I think he's
always London with being a finisher
potato and certainly Finland you it's
seen as a Finnish architect how finish
do you think is his work and influence
from the finish a particular scene I'm
gonna let you take it
one day he actually he didn't you know
remember that list I gave he was a he
loved list it did list about everything
is the what we didn't list about the
list about things to do but one of the
least he always kept on remaking was the
list of architects the Masters and how
he ranked them
I think
I'm out there was there but he was not
never made it to the top three so later
in life he did visit Lee alumni day and
but I think there was a
you know it's a day sir may was finished
by birth but I don't think it was he
wasn't he wasn't I think well first of
all he was American educated architect
so that
very complex so I and it's always it
always comes up but I think it's
to us and what in
what would it mean to be a beer
have be a finish I think certainly the
influence of all those furniture and i
think i was in that
competition there was a
affinities that
when it is but and I think hard to talk
about some sort of essence or finish
nested would somehow naturally you know
come out of him
how would you ever then think about
certain and in terms of an international
context like in your book about although
you talk about all those relationship to
the international context and he's
particular persona as being finished
within the international context then if
we think of Sauron and as an American
architect or finished in an
international context did he do you have
a relationship to an international
context however that made the
competitive and outdoor that case is an
interesting one goes out or so actively
sought this
connections he was incredible travel or
he was you know spend as much time out
of the country s in inside the country I
mean that's one of the characteristics
of you know in a small country you have
to have to go out or if you want to get
somewhere so alpha certainly was a most
of travel and active you know contact
taker and and and had a huge network in
the end of his life or actually from
from early on but Simon was kind of a
magnet to sign an office where people
came to and it was it kind of the kind
of reverse that he was located in the
office was in Bloomfield Hills Michigan
but everybody was somebody came through
that office and people came to work
there so you know he was never I think
he's kind of that from the
correspondence his night away curiously
out the hallways never been considered
and intellectual he was much more kind
of keeping up with with with the
discourse and lithium and what was going
on son it was not the intellectual in
that way and there's been a very few
comments in his correspondence that
indicate that he was he was really you
know fully kind of embedded in the in
the architecture of this course of his
his time in the you know intellectual
sense yeah but he was a magnet for for
talent from all over the world but then
also we should keep in mind that he all
of his work he really created in the US
apart from a few projects that he worked
on competitions and so on in Finland and
of course we can't underline the fact
that his father was an immense influence
on him and his father was definitely a
finish our cadet well yeah I you know I
it's sort of interesting to me to wonder
in what sense does that the question of
national origins and heritage makes
sense in what sense is that kind of a
question
resting today I'm not denying its
interest I'm just saying that it's quite
clear that it's not self-evident and you
know in terms and I also speak by the
way as the director of the Center for
the Study of American architecture Julio
represents Finnish Cultural Institute so
so we're here to overcome shall we say
the the National frame but not
necessarily in the interest of a kind of
default internationalism because I must
say sorriness father was not a
cosmopolitan in in the classic modernist
says he was provincial but he was out
the lesson right right but I'm sorry
eliel saarinen he was it was not
provincial culturally you know and I'm
not speaking about Finland versus the US
he you know he if anything part of what
arrows are in it i think inherited from
his father dare i say was his american
was a kind of provincialism that he'd
translated into an American provincials
and the but in the sense that there was
still the residue especially as you say
an ileal of the desire to define
national culture through architecture
and this was one of his his important
roles you know in his own in his in his
home country he was a bit lost when you
came to to the to the states Elia was he
was scared by Detroit and and by people
who didn't you know sort of seem so
familiar and and cranbrook reproduce it
it is in this many ways this environment
I've been talking about the Heritage in
the background and the teaching kind of
cranbrook really you can feel it you can
still feel it crime the anxiety about
virgins and about groundedness and being
of a place and and so in that sense the
displacement I would you know sort of
Sarah the displacement is sort of basic
its structural and the fact that these
figures of the 20th century are living
that displacement is it sounds more
interesting than what they thought they
were doing
so the interesting about cranbrook
course of course you know any I grew up
with this in this very kind of seclusion
ol Ike we had in clay the hills in kemah
date time and maybe the city they were
missing clay by me to go into yes yeah
yeah I made it I mean the same baby you
know the the the cranbrook is the same
similar kind of in clay by midday
bell-like riot going on in Detroit you
know why they were having masquerades
this is sort of weird parallel
university so I think that that is it's
almost a sense that history was going
like in a different track family was
always moving to these different places
and it'll be the different temporal fame
in the middle
I had a question I guess that follows up
on his father maybe not on his
provincialism but on his father's
writing on form because I knew even if
eridan right very much as father
produced in a fairly hefty book that's
all about the derivation of forum both
and it's sort of organic derivation and
its permutations through history which
reads is actually very close to a whole
set of would say 19th century German
traditions that follow through with
Gideon and I wonder the extent to which
I mean I know that father and son worked
together on a number of pretty
interesting projects that to my
knowledge or not in the Yale archive not
documented there I wonder in that sense
about the relationship between the
father and son in producing a variation
on formal thinking through a modernist
idiom if there's been research on that
or what your thoughts are it's it's
interesting I don't talk about a little
bit in the in the article enter in the
book and I think it's the book was again
I think it was important for for arrow
as well and I think what he gets from
his thesis kind of a sense and it comes
to back to these questions about about
you know silence relationship to time
and took place and and you know this is
a sense that you know this idea of even
the circulation of forms you know that
how they's almost like poop Larry an
idea that they did the form circulate
and they can kind of pop up the same
forms in different different cultural
context you know you take a circle and
it kind of disorder idea of the eternal
form and I'm sorry was very the way he
talks about architecture it's this sort
of which you know for somebody who is
taught in modern day so it's like you
know let's talk about what's today and
what's really the burning problems of
contemporary society
this preoccupation with form that you
know that that has this was a weird
historical trajectory that that you know
that's also very very organic I think
it's it it gives it you know the kind of
you know as the kind of weirdness of
sadness like where to place him
historically cause he's preoccupied with
the sort of discourse that he inherits
from the father like you said from the
90th century really that's very
different from you know what was going
on on on around him
you know sorry i totally agree that that
the aliens writings underestimated in a
sense but it did give you know this is
funny story but you probably know this
but when there was the competition for
the arch they both entered it and this
telegram arrives you know Saarinen wins
you broke out the champagne for the
father later clarified and i think we
saw that that sort of summarizes this
this issue because if anything I you
know I don't want to kind of
psychologizing so thoroughly but it does
to some extent demand that in a way what
it demands is a kind of historical lens
that is capable of accounting for the
father-son relationship psycho socially
as well as sort of professional because
both are occurring in the office and in
the house and everywhere they've got
everything is happening together all the
time so to be accurate historically
somehow have to be able to do that but
you know it's fair to say in the
writings that what you know what sorry
enero inherits as it were in translation
into english sort of from a leo is his
organism but i think he modifies that
organism rather unconsciously because he
doesn't theorize it means you're right i
mean aliens is a kind of 19th century
you know organism has a very curious
ideas about race for example and things
like this and arrows finds in a kind of
let's say dispersed discursive
environment that kind of you know in
other words not by reading this book in
that book in that book and then like
translating those books into the project
but it is sent inserting his the problem
of organism that he you know innocence
has been developing with his father into
the American corporate environment in
particular aero innovates a kind of
systems organizes along with others not
not just zero and so the curtain wall
winds up becoming the kind of unit that
can be analogized to the cell because
that's that's one of the great diagrams
and that that book which i think is a
interesting but awful book and and any
of our in the module and the iteration
becomes an open-ended system rather than
a closed closed form that's another
better way in completely formal terms
one of the very interesting dilemmas in
trying to make sense of this that that
is that they're really really I did have
two classes of siren and projects
formally they're the closed forms which
are probably the more famous monster to
a sport and then there are the you know
I think more specific well there are the
patterned buildings that the open-ended
modular structure sometimes they come
together a little another one more quick
story they often I was trying to suggest
that you know certain problems arise
when when when these things enter the
real world but one of things that
happened in your way sorry in in England
in London embassy in Grosvenor Square is
is that they wanted there was a
the whole debate in Congress about and
about the eagle you know because it was
just a blank buildings like a pattern
and so the Congress got involved the
American Congress got involved to insist
that there should be a kind of
recognizable and shape of an eagle
archive emblem on there and I've always
said that they sort of made a joke out
of it in the office I never asked
anybody maybe I love you and your
discussions ever discover this but that
you know it was so gross it's so
enlarged and kind of overblown that it's
almost chaotic realization so anyway
well it just was interesting and this is
probably tangential but was interested
in reinholds discussion of the spiritual
aspect of where the kind of conflict at
kresge chapter the chapel in the
auditorium and if you look at it airzone
writings on form there is this odd kind
of sort of latent essentialism that kind
of services which which could have I
think does relate back to a normal kind
of romantic notion of what kind of
spiritual aspect of kind of formal
expression that in other reasons as much
as say for instance UWA is celebrated as
this kind of symbol of contemporary
notions of life and kind of
technological transformation there's
this kind of undercurrent of a kind of
recourse to the certain repetitive
values or sort of underlying kind of
cultural meanings that architecture
should convey
carry that that he tends to kind of
reiterate in a lot of the brief amounts
of text that he does write about his own
work so there is this kind of
interesting and I think it is true it
happens in a way between the two
building technologies as well these more
repetitive structures which are based
maybe more on organization and the ones
that are more about the kind of Morganna
scism relative to the idea of the kind
of closed formal expression of these
plastic buildings like TWA but there's
always that sort of undercurrent that I
think is kind of presents or latent or
implicit within the work well you will
see that that you know like the diagram
I showed about the arts this of the
force or the obsession which was not you
know shared by others about geometry the
pure geometric forms and the kind of
essential isn't that went hand in hand
with that and the kind of cosmological
systems that went yeah i must say that i
feel the need to insist that another
name for what we're talking about his
theology and and it's not so crypto
always it's not so kind of sublimated
more abstracted in science sometimes it
is but in that sense you can very
usefully serve as a sort of cipher it
kind of a means to decode the you know
we talk we do usually speak about these
things in terms of romanticism Atlantica
to kind of Expressionism sometimes or
naturalism but decode the sort of
quote-unquote as a non secular dimension
dimensions of modernism and not only in
the cloud institutional kind of literal
sense of religious buildings it's it's
one of the great historical dilemma
historiographical I think problems of
dilemmas and very interesting ones for
you know kind of writing the history of
modern architecture and it's kind of
compounded after the war with the
incense the religious turn of the
country itself I mean it just goes
together with the eagle because it's
also the
it's also McCarthyism the when they
opened the auditorium at MIT the one of
the problem burchard this guy from
humanities was the charge of kind of the
opening ceremonies and and so he wanted
to get Aaron Copland the composer to
perform in that but a couple in had had
his name had appeared on certain lists
this is the 50s and and so they
performed a background check on him and
that background check was presented to
the president at the University before
he was invited this is public community
archives you know it was judged he was
just okay he was not yes and and you
know that's the environment in which in
which a lot of this work is done and and
it need you know it needs to be kind of
evaluated with historical kind of
specificity that plus the this sort of
crisis of conscience that is that is
kind of summarized in the mushroom cloud
and I think you know it's not there
everywhere in all these projects but to
the extent that siren and like a lot
like it in the late Alto like the lake
bubu giri like Khan is associated with a
kind of post-war humanism it's sometimes
called a kind of softening of the sharp
edges of modern architecture a kind of
restoration of meaning you know a return
of the kind of soul then then you know
this needs to be to me to be confronted
mr. sarin and certainly was very
fortunate
name some names
now look I was kind of I was serious
about naming names because i think it's
sort of an interesting kind of thematic
you know for the panel to think what it
means to do talk about this today and
since you identify this as a persistent
symptom in a way this this problem of
the architects relationship to their you
know there's a cultural and social
environment particularly if they don't
make claims if they don't write or or
speak you know systematically about that
I you know I think that that it doesn't
matter that much what the answer is
about this particular architect I must
say I think what you're kind of
identifying is is it is very important
and is it kind of interesting it again
poses problems for us and trying to
understand it because we are trained in
a sense to to take into account the
architects intentions with a very
particulate adore you know gets you get
if you have a problem when the architect
doesn't tell you what those are but the
act of not having intentions and
precisely especially for someone who
grew up with the kind of privileges that
he did this is you know they grew up in
a kind of high bourgeois environment and
to any sense immersion that environment
as an anti-intellectual and this guy was
kind of crazy who's a little bit kind of
you know like I think you have to sort
of acknowledge that there was something
idiosyncratic let's say about this
individual personality and the lists
mirror writing all kinds of things and
but but the but definitely I mean I was
not antagonistic to you know
universities for example he was actually
one of his most eloquent theorizing is
about the University I think actually is
it nice article that
we got a lot about this and and it
really is he was very thoughtful about
what is a university and again it's
curious because he doesn't actually seem
to be the time you know and so in and
you know it's more like okay what's the
result what's on the table as a result
of this strange mixture is really what
we need to take into account so much to
kind of say well to generalize or
intelligence a architects are or are not
functions or symptoms of their fathers
but than others and you know your aunts
and uncles and then you know the
environment the times the zeitgeist etc
so I mean you know sure that that's
represented kind of strand of
interpretive analysis but it does seem
to me that the net result of these this
sort of set of social and cultural
formations and behaviors is sufficiently
enigmatic in its own terms to sort of
change the question I guess that's what
I'm kind of getting at is that that
that's what I think is so interesting
it's always fascinating about this kind
of figure who doesn't really fit but
it's interesting also i mean the
comparison to the father I mean here he
is the father who you know produced his
significant work in film under law
around the time of Finnish independence
I mean there was a very clear project it
was part of I mean there's no question
about it and there's a very uniform
style so here's the sun that emerges in
mid century America if you look at his
clientele alone I mean it was clearly
the whole is who in in American culture
they were university is major
universities major companies the
American government but if you look at
the kind of diversity of the class you
know the client body and if you would
ask them you know what is the project
the day share it would be very difficult
you know what I'm what I'm saying so
it's a very different kind of cultural
social mill year than
then you know and the kind of finish
turn of the century milia where there is
a project I mean national is project
whatever you say but they said so you
know you always say like what was sudden
and kind of what what is the kind of
driving thing that that that throw you
know kind of unifies all the probably
it's very hard to have given so many
forces or so
well we can because they're actually
okay so the father has I don't want to
trip I'm I think that two things
occurred to me in this discussion that's
taking place by the way thank you for
your oh you're very fine toxin
especially I mark did a wonderful job of
reinterpreting the meta interpretation
of meta interpretations excellent two
things I occurred to me about Sara know
who might didn't know I met at least I
don't say I know my bed but one thing is
there was a program and was called the
American Century and Henry was mapped it
out right before the Second World War
and people truly believed in it and at
the end of the war all these architects
who were beginning to work for the
government in the embassies it comes out
in the catalog and the corporations like
General Motors away there was a program
about America taking leadership in the
world as it had never before and showing
the rest of the world what capitalism
and democracy together can produce adult
I think it's unfair to categorize as
angry English frustrated intellectuals
and architects where the country wasn't
coming together after the war was losing
power and position took out against the
Americans whom they resent it and that's
a complicated story but England was
declining in America was rising batam
and others the other thing about it I
saarinen that occurred to me for the
first time maybe it's very obvious what
I'd never thought about it of all the
major architects of his generation the
forum givers as Ava he was the only one
who wasn't indoctrinated at Harvard it
was really word he was never
indoctrinated he wanted to be a sculptor
but we very remember that he went spent
a year in Paris studying sculpture then
he came back into I guess he wasn't so
good at it he was good
but not as good as he thought he should
be then he goes to Yale which was not a
doctrinaire place at that time or ever
and um and he it comes to modernism and
he leads his father to stylistic
modernism but not through an educational
process through annex reading seeing so
it also was extremely well traveled it's
not true they didn't travel it when you
FDA we spent two years traveling we have
evidence of what he saw it seems
incredible drawings and stuff so he was
very well trouble he traveled after the
war even knows that we even have his
travel slides my god he was hardly a
provincial and all the architects of his
generation both hated him and loved him
they admired him enormously they only
hated him because he had the best
commissions and clients whether they
were university presidents or corporate
presidents adored talking to him this
man could not have been boring or
without ideas it's just because he
didn't write them down it's only I would
apologize my generation and now your
generation is obsessively writing
everything down endlessly argue it's all
our fault i take responsibility as much
as others but architects in those days
didn't write endless justifications for
beach houses and and whatever
you can't judge sarin and by today's
standards what everybody is saying and I
just do we have to realize who he was
and what he accomplished in his own
extraordinary critical milieu and the
mad men folk really understand that
that'll be tomorrow some pure interest
yeah you know I mean it's true then
thank you for your the contextualization
which I do think is important but I I
think in a way that's sort of a sort of
sane response to the previous question
that it may be better not to judge the
person even the work and to try to
understand what the implication of this
let's say it's the American Century
right you know that would be a very
interesting thing I think to you know
put like on the table and discuss not
just how it sort of played out but also
what was at stake under the
circumstances and I do think that that
the crisis of the conscience that that
you know that he to some extent serviced
or found a way to articulate in his kind
of in his work in his sort of softening
of the modern stadium is this
precipitous and probably in his jokes
also because I you know I think he
probably was a pretty engaging fellow is
is probably belongs to that it belongs
to that you know project which may or
may not have been written down it
certainly was you're right i mean
another context and I certainly wouldn't
disparage him for not running because I
frankly don't particularly enjoy writing
reading most of what gets written down
guitars apology so then is telling us
one more question oh you want no I was
just going to building off a little bit
on that and Bob's comments as well it's
interesting in checks position to the
previous comments there is there's this
notion of the incredible privilege which
actually sarin and acknowledge of being
on the one hand born into this is sort
of highly area thi kind of context of
the Father and cram book etc but also
being kind of privileged to be
practicing this in this time of general
affluence and culture and to have access
to these incredible kind of clients both
a kind of corporate governmental and
institutional level at the same time
there there is this kind of interesting
quality and one of the things that I
found most kind of fascinating about
even some of the anecdotal stories about
the office and how they pursued work was
at the same time a kind of curious let's
say a kind of uneasy quality that i
think is kind of fascinating that
there's this kind of continual sort of
search and kind of research and a kind
of obsession with iteration which
actually find is kind of part of the
pathology of practice today in a certain
way which in a way is sort of
contradictory to the image of sarah
ninas kind of the sort of smooth
operator who's kind of kind of extending
his influence into these various spheres
and kind of taking advantage of this of
this kind of productivity so in the one
hand there's this kind of incredible
let's say engagement with and then a
kind of latching on to the technology's
practices and operations of the day on
the other hand there's there's a certain
let's say
1 consider begin to identify a kind of
continual search a kind of I don't want
to put in negative terms but almost a
kind of a lack of knowing where one is
going and that emerges into a kind of
experimentalism so this sort of
obsession with in the office of
multiplication of variations of
redirecting iterations upon iterations
is kind of fascinating to me in that
regard and I guess as a as an architect
as a designer it's a kind of pathology
that I can kind of relate to at a
certain scale than this the sort of
anxiety about discerning what might be
the kind of right response to a
situation at some level gets kind of
played out in this almost sort of
neurotic kind of repetition which which
i think is a kind of curious counterpart
to the to the perceived kind of
confidence of the of the era you were
earlier saying that how certain is
difficult for architecture students to
understand at the same time Aronson has
been receiving a lot of tension within
the field of historic preservation thing
is that considering the fact that within
the field of architecture and InDesign
could it's the criticism critiques and
practices are constantly evolving
changing how do you see that the next
generation of of designers and scholars
are going to see Saracen and his peers
20 30 years from now
because keep in mind the student you
teach now we're the ones who are going
to be taking over the firm's and the
positions of scholarship in the future
that's why you all do such a great job
educating us yes yes no you're right
definitely be prepared to take over the
world the preservation question I did
yeah that is a very interesting one with
this I guess a very simple question that
it would have to be left open and it is
what exactly is being preserved if what
we just discussed was true if there
really is a kind of let a cultural
apparatus a cultural project sort of you
know it's not just the bricks and mortar
as it were but there are meanings there
are you know intentional or not then
then it's the one of the questions would
be you know what do those how do those
values such as they are translate into
this context it's not just a jetblue
kind of you know updating
that seems to me that the sort of
relevant sort of way to think about this
no I mean it's actually interesting
because one of the thing about the
sudden and buildings and some of them
became kind of defunct totally during
the you know very creepy the TWA
terminal for example the technology
surpassed the terminal very soon so
there is this sort of accelerated the
mode as we know the same four yards also
is it's you know kind of disconnected
from the it doesn't really work as a
city city it's a big Park so there are
lot of issues there the Bell Labs
building was to be even for American
Express to take over so a lot of
feelings so then you have to get you
know decided you know does this building
as enough cultural value that no matter
what will try to somehow make it work
and I think that's that's at issue at
many of these preservation cases I know
that there's a competition now for maybe
mark you are doing the same for yard
competition and it would be a huge
challenge to make it make make make the
park work for the city you know notice
or icon for the city but actually as
something that is used and you know by
the cities and so it's it's it's a
tricky tricky questions we saw kind of
images but you know so the truth you
know like they London embassy also that
stopped working for the for the client
then there was a huge discussion about
whether that should be preserved so it's
it's it's not an easy question just
going to briefly build on that I mean
there's only one had the physical
preservation of the actual artifacts
that we've been referring to on the
other hand in terms of relevance I mean
I do think that there's there's the
notion of saron ins legacy relative to a
whole series of issues that continue to
kind of either plagued us today or that
we have kind of the opportunity to
explore depending upon how one one looks
at
and so I think it would be as a student
kind of useful to consider his
relationship to the kind of technology
kind of experimentalism and and kind of
techniques of materialization and
fabrication which are kind of obviously
a kind of ongoing sort of obsession
there's the kind of relationship to kind
of notions of kind of program and the
kind of client and there's this curious
way in which sarin is able to kind of
operate within sort of very sort of
let's say loaded and kind of charge
circumstances and to kind of produce
architectures which on the one end can
be seen as expressions of these you know
these sort of institutions and
organizations but at the other hand have
this kind of idiosyncratic and adding
enigmatic quality that we're all kind of
referring to and that's part of the kind
of fascination so I think there's on the
one hand the physical artifacts of the
architecture on the other hand there is
being kind of look going to be on that
it at the ways in which they begin to
kind of reveal certain approaches to
trajectories that are still sort of
present today
you